are building a second school and
Revitalize the use of the Cherokee
language
by the way she spent a lot of time on
other reservations other nations as well
I'm worried she's not going to come home
one of these days when she goes you
think I'm joking I'm telling you if I
hear more about the navajos than I hear
about me
um
you all think I'm kidding done
y'all think I'm kidding but I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report it's
December 1st 2022 we're live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV subscribe
if you have not particularly at
rumble.com
Reuben report and if you want to play
along during the show chat with our
people and possibly get me a message
live
during this internet broadcast go to
reubenreport.locals.com we've got a
Community Q a for you today but I wanted
to start with some narrative collapsing
stuff because I think that's what we're
seeing right now probably more than
anything else with Elon taking over
Twitter and everybody's freaking out
about it and oh my god there might be
more voices out there saying more things
and more people might be sharing
information or as they call it
misinformation we all might speak freely
we might communicate we might actually
exchange ideas on the internet
no no no we can't have that uh so I
wanted to start with this Ricky Gervais
clip from a couple years ago it's
actually from 2020 right before the
kovid lockdowns and it's sort of
interesting to look back on it because
there were a couple people out there
Ricky included you might be at the top
of the list who were calling out so much
of the inconsistency and the BS and the
way we placate China and of course
that's related to Elon and the Apple iOS
store and whether Twitter will stay on
there and everything else and then we're
gonna play a little uh clip from 2017 of
Apple CEO Tim Cook
praising China because you know China
while they lock their people up and
they've got drones flying around saying
you can't leave your house our companies
like the NBA and apple seem to love them
let's talk about bullion Max real quick
and then we'll get to it uh you guys
know as inflation surpasses high as not
seen in 40 years the value of the dollar
is decreasing with every passing day
you're paying more at the pump the
grocery store for cars and housing
facing paper money is worth less guys
the timing couldn't be any better for my
new sponsor bullion Max Boolean Max is a
direct to Consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security for your
family in times of Crisis and here's why
I love bullying max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metal space
offer some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website I wanted to
help get you started so I worked out a
special offer with them just for you get
bullion Max's silver starter kit at
employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com Dave the kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including a silver
American eagle and a Sylvan a silver
Australian kangaroo this offer is
limited to just one per household so get
yours now go to bullionmax.com Dave and
now back to me all right so let's start
as I sip my coffee
with a little throwback clip you know
I'm sure a bunch of you have seen
portions of this but I think you'll see
what I'm doing here uh this is the
Golden Globes 2020 right before the
world went to hell in a handbasket Ricky
Gervais
the game with a morning show a superb
drama yeah
[Applause]
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
China so well you say you woke but the
companies you work for I mean
unbelievable Apple Amazon Disney if Isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so if you do win
an award tonight but don't use it as a
platform to make a political speech
right you're in no position to lecture
the public about anything you know
nothing about the real world most of you
spent less time in school than Greta
thundberg so if you win right come up
accept your little Awards thank your
agent and your God
so
good he's good uh I mentioned that that
was right before lockdowns because uh
call me a crazy conspiracy theorist we
have my tinfoil hat today uh you know
the fact that the world went to hell in
a handbasket just as people started
talking about what reality is right we
were talking about that we were talking
about the Epstein stuff there was some
people talking about some stuff and then
the whole world disappeared in
censorship and covid and misinformation
disinformation etc etc but what really
of course is interesting about that is
these people in Hollywood they love love
love
what do they love they love money they
love access all of these things and they
don't necessarily Love Freedom which is
why so many people have no problem with
apple which we as we talked about
yesterday on their new iOS update it's
actually insane what they are doing as
as literally millions of people in China
are are standing up against the
government so that they can go live
their lives and not be trapped in condos
and giant apartment buildings and shut
down cities and all of those things
Apple literally updated the app did not
put it in the text of the update that
airdrop was going to be shut off and
limited or Limited at worst but shut off
or Limited at best shut off at worst and
that way people couldn't share videos
with each other so that's what apple is
doing here but you don't hear anyone
from the NBA talking about that you
don't hear LeBron James talking about
that you don't hear many people from
Hollywood talking about that you hear
Elon Musk talking about that you hear a
couple people hear you know crazy right
wing type people talking about it here
but in essence they don't want people to
know what's going on in China and apple
is helping them do it let's shift a
little bit because this is consistent
with what Apple has done for quite some
time it's not fun talking about Apple
I've got one of these things I get it
it's in everyone's pocket it's probably
spying on me right now it could post
what I'm doing on the internet that
would be weird here's Apple CEO Tim Cook
in 2017 praising China and talking about
how their leadership aligns with his
China's done an unbelievable job of
lifting people out of poverty they've
done an incredible job and I mean far
beyond what any country has done we were
talking about 19 mid 90s to today the
biggest change is the number of people
that have been pulled out of poverty
by far and we should all applaud that
and we should all feel good about it and
so there are in in the environmental
leadership today
is very clear and it aligns completely
with Apple's values the Chinese uh
environmental governments I mean they're
they're very fixated on on uh doing the
right things to avert climate change and
this is something that means a lot to us
as well and so what what we always try
to do is find the areas where you can
work together find the areas of
commonality and then the things that you
disagree with take time to understand
how somebody sees it and if I'm going to
get criticized for that then so be it so
it's really interesting here first off
China right now is opening more coal
plants than any other country on Earth
but he likes again this is back into
that 2017. he likes China because of
what they're doing with green energy but
what he really likes is the same thing
that the NBA likes he's a businessman
and I don't besmerge him as a
businessman a businessman is in the
business of business apple is a company
wants to make money and what do
companies do once you've exhausted the
amount of people that you can make money
from in the United States right they've
kind of Hit the limit most of us have
iPhones most of us have their products
you might pay for iMusic or iTunes or
whatever it is or you're downloading
movies then they have to find new
markets to go to so China is a massive
Market in that they've got billions of
people over there uh here's some info
from Bloomberg on on the coal plant
situation because again he's praising
them for going green this is from
September of 22. China put more new coal
plants into operation last year than the
rest of the world combined and its
proposed coal mines account for almost a
third of the global total Bazaar that I
don't see Tim Cook talking [ __ ] about
them today very very weird anyway let's
link some of that stuff to to Elon and
everything else that's going on in the
world there's a couple questions about
that in the Community Q a we'll start
with Annie hi Dave do you plan and on
coming back to Naples I saw you when you
appeared at seed to table a few months
back it would be great to see you again
you know I took the the team to see the
table again a couple weeks ago when we
were driving back from the the DeSantis
Victory rally on Election Day uh it's
really fantastic over there like it's
just if you haven't been there if you
haven't been to Southwest Florida and
checked out this place this was the
place seat to table that stayed open
during the lockdown CNN did this
insanely slanderous piece about how they
were going to kill all the old people
because they weren't making the people
behind the registers wear masks and all
the nonsense and they just stayed open
and they've got great products there and
good people and everyone everyone's
happy and there's American flags there
it's wild
um will I be back yes I am going to do
something you know so Naples obviously
Southwest Florida that was hit by
Hurricane Ian and you guys know my my
feelings about Sanibel Island so we are
going to do a fundraiser at some point
I've been laying some groundwork there
we're trying to get it we need a little
more infrastructure to do things
properly because right now it's still
all about rebuilding the stuff over
there but we will get there stay tuned
for that uh Freedom isn't free says hi
Dave do you think Americans are finally
ready for a third party
well we do have a third party we have
well we have several third parties I
mean the two biggest ones although they
they aren't that big obviously you're
the libertarian party and the green
party
um look they don't really function that
well I mean as far as the Libertarians
and I like Libertarians I go to a lot of
libertarian conferences I'm happy to
debate Libertarians when it comes to
drivers licenses and weed that's what it
always boils down to with these guys
um but they're very very unorganized
right it's like trying to get a bunch of
like feral cats in a box like
Libertarians disagree on everything and
I think that that's the proof in the
pudding like every four years they kind
of put out a presidential candidate and
usually not a great one right they've
had a couple bad ones and they don't do
much work on the ground they've gotten a
little bit better at that the real issue
with the libertarian party is let's say
the libertarian party could get five
percent of the vote which would be
roughly five times what they normally
get they usually get about a percent in
a in a presidential election it's like
you get five percent I vote you most
likely took a huge chunk of that from
the Republicans and congratulations you
just helped the Democrats that's just
how it is you could do the other version
of that with the greens and the and the
Democrats so I personally
talk about this all the time my personal
belief would be that if you're a
Libertarian and you want to smoke weed
and you want to marry who you want to
marry and all that stuff there is some
home for you in in what I would say is
this new Republican party there really
is and you should just be fighting to to
ensure that that is okay you take a guy
like DeSantis who is in large part a
Libertarian right he was one of the
founders of the freedom caucus and he's
leading as someone that's trying to get
government out of the way I think
there's room to work with these with
these guys some of them may want bigger
government than you do some of them may
want more regulation Etc et cetera but
it's like there's a way to work together
and realize that you want to live in the
same country with these people so I
think that that's better than a third
party like yes like conceptually I like
it it might be great but you know
there's governments all over the world
that have many many parties and have to
put coalitions together and then the
smallest party ends up having the most
power because they're the one that puts
them over the threshold so uh you gotta
The Grass Is Always Greener Nathan says
on Monday I walked by a Raphael Warren
not campaign bus where he was trying to
Rally students at my college for votes
but he's not getting mine good for you
even though we defeated Stacey Abrams
it's strange to see my long time solidly
red straight LED solidly Red State trade
with Florida to become the new swing
state of the South do you think there's
any hope that Georgia will find its way
back towards say the solid red
leadership it's good neighbor Florida
has become it's a good question look
Brian Kemp won Stacy Abrams election
deniers Stacey Abrams she's gone I just
heard this morning now she's lobbying
the Biden administration because she
wants to become the head of the FCC this
woman has literally no resume other than
losing for governor twice she has done
nothing although she did take that
picture with her [ __ ] eating grin with
all the kids in masks you may remember
that one a couple months back
Georgia probably should be read so Kemp
winning by a lot kind of in uh kind of
implies that it is Ken born by nine
points which is pretty big and now the
Warnock Walker situation they're they're
in this election or this the second
election for them and we'll see what
happens
but I'm going to put it this way
um we didn't get that Red Wave we you
know and most of the Senate seats either
stayed blue or some actually flip blue
so I don't think there's you should have
any great faith that Herschel Walker is
going to win if he wins it would be nice
but I would say at this point at least
the Republicans have the house right at
least they have the house they can kind
of just throw a wrench into most of the
stuff that Biden and the walksters want
to do for the next two years and then
and then we see what happens after that
Jen says what do you think about
neuralink would you ever implant a chip
in your own body or your kids
um
you know if you would have asked me this
like 10 years ago I probably would have
been more into like the robotic body
parts maybe swapping out an arm no
Connor you're giving me the no you're a
pure he's a purebred he doesn't want any
robotics in his body I probably would
like I love sci-fi so I would have been
like more amenable to it I think at this
point now knowing what we know about big
Tech knowing the way we're being
manipulated when we're not connected to
these things knowing the way that
endless scrolling is rewiring our brain
and God knows what this device is
emanating what that's doing to us and
all of those things like not much good
is going to come out of it so while you
know at 46 years old I will be alive
when they're really implanting this
stuff I don't think I will be implanting
anything in my brain or my body or my
children's bodies uh that would be I
think that's a safe assessment of the
situation uh but I look forward to you
guys doing it I think that'll be great
for you uh Snow Baby Says any exciting
predictions for politics or culture
that might pop up before the new year
covid 1572 Newsom coming out as a drag
queen Biden kicking the bucket and his
double body his body double assuming
office like in the movie Dave great
movie by the way uh Disney actually
making something worthwhile again well
certainly the last one's not going to
happen you know Disney released this
movie what was it called again the movie
from this weekend the Disney released uh
strangeland or something like that
strange world yeah and it completely
bombed they this was probably their last
like directly woke movie and people have
just had it with that nonsense so I
don't sense Disney turning around
anytime soon and we did play those
videos uh yesterday from Bob Iger who is
the once and now future CEO of Disney uh
saying that they're going to be a little
less woke but it's in the system it's in
the system so unless he's gonna fire
probably 20 of the workforce at Disney
it's not going anywhere anytime soon as
far as predictions for the rest of the
year
um
I mean I think the main what it all
boils down to right now is is whether
the Democrats are really going to try to
do something on Elon whether that's
somehow
regulating Twitter further or looking
into his other businesses I mean I think
the most dangerous thing that has come
out of this Administration in the last
couple weeks was Biden at that
ridiculous Tick Tock Summit so the the
Biden Administration invited a bunch of
tick-tockers tick tock which we know is
a Chinese spy app it is they get all the
data on your phone I do not have Tick
Tock um do you have Tick Tock you got
the tick tock you The Tick Tock right no
no one here has Tick Tock okay we don't
Tick Tock uh but it's a Chinese spyware
that everyone's putting on their phones
then the Biden Administration literally
invites a bunch of tick tockers to the
White House to ask him questions and one
of the questions is basically what are
you going to do about Elon Musk and
Biden says well we don't know that he's
done anything wrong but you know we're
going to look into it we got to look
into it and that is exactly the reverse
of what the government is supposed to do
the government isn't supposed to go I
don't know if there's a problem but we
can certainly find a problem because
guess what guys they're always going to
find a problem uh so I think seeing what
the government will or won't do related
to the Elon Twitter thing is is the most
important thing and also yesterday Elon
implied in a tweet
that there was election interference
that he has records of whatever was
going on with either the administration
or the intelligence Services related to
elections like he's got the stuff that's
why Elizabeth Warren's freaking out
about him we'll find out where that all
goes uh proudest mom says Dave what's
your most vivid memory from your
childhood slash high school years uh
I'll tell you something that happened to
me in I believe it was 10th or 11th
grade science at Long Island Syosset
High School uh I was in environmental
science which was I wasn't great at
science I was more of a social studies
guy I wasn't a great science student so
this it was not I don't want to say it
was a slow class but it wasn't you know
top of the line biology we weren't doing
it it was environmental science like you
know do you know what war the difference
between water and air is that kind of
thing anyway they take us out back to
the school and there was a little Pond
back there and we were supposed to like
do tests in the pond it was this gross
little Pond and uh I there was a bunch
of rocks going out into the little Lake
there a little Pond and I jumped out to
a couple threw over a couple rocks and
I'm standing out there and I had a
plankton catcher you guys ever have a
plankton catcher when you're growing up
this like device that you kind of spin
around on a rope and you throw it in the
water and then you catch Plankton and
then I don't know you're supposed to
examine everything anyway we're whirling
this thing around like everyone look at
me I got my Plankton catcher throw it it
was somehow attached to my hand and
pulled me right into the lake completely
submerged
wet dripping sopping Plankton everywhere
as you can imagine end up walking back
into school dripping dripping wet and
I'm walking down the hallway because I
was going to go to the gym locker room
to just put on my gym clothes and a
teacher stopped me because I didn't have
a hall pass and I got detention I'm
soaking wet like as if I was really up
to no good
that's the type of childhood I had there
you go Elizabeth says where do you and
your team get your news from to make
your show every day uh well I hate to
tell you I mean it's it's mostly Twitter
like that is the place that's why I
always say to you guys it's like if
you're not on Twitter God bless you
don't get on there really there don't
like you've done something right in life
probably and you're probably highly
productive and happy but the thing is
that that Twitter is the pr wire for the
world it is where the stuff is breaking
all the time where not only are you
seeing the headlines but you're seeing
what the taste makers talk about it I
think one of the reasons that Trump
doesn't feel like sort of as on the
ground like getting what's going on as
he used to is because he's off Twitter
it's probably good for him in a certain
way that he's off Twitter and he's doing
his thing at truth and it's kind of
working but he's not in the game as much
the game is Twitter whether we like it
or not but then you know we check all
the usual spots so we we Source ours I
try to source as many stories from from
things that do not uh align with us but
that that can be somewhat tricky but you
know we get stuff from The Blaze and
daily wire post millennial I think is
really great Tom Elliott is one of the
guys that I get a lot of the video clips
from as well as Greg Price Washington
Free Beacon uh but yeah it is
it is on the Twitter it is on the
Twitter what can I tell you uh Naomi
says how come we haven't heard any more
about the Paul Pelosi case isn't that
bizarre
remember some guy broke into Paul
Pelosi's house and he was like a nudist
or something and it was into BLM and
antifa but everyone called him a crazy
right winger and he was there to kill
Nancy Pelosi and Paul Pelosi or
something and it turns out that the
window that the guy broke into the glass
was on the outside which is very bizarre
because if you were punching your way in
generally the glass would be on the
inside and then there were were reports
that the that Paul Pelosi actually
opened the door for him and for the
police officer and now we don't hear
anything about it suddenly it's probably
not a crazy right-winger that did this
very strange that none of the cameras
worked that Nancy Pelosi's house she
didn't have any security that day the
data on the cameras didn't save so I'm
gonna have to really think about this
one I think you guys get the point uh
lady broad says how do you visualize
Elon musk's status one year from now
that's a great question because man it's
all happening so fast but I I suspect
that Twitter is going to look very very
different than it looks right now I
think he wants to turn it partly into a
video site but I think he also wants to
turn it into a Commerce site I think
he's really trying to clean up the Bots
um I think that his biggest challenge
will be sort of what I referenced before
which is that the government is not
going to be happy that there is a guy
who does not really align with them who
has access to information about what
they've done like he he is literally
sitting on a dossier there is just no
doubt that on his desk at Twitter he's
got a bunch of paper and on that paper
is the info related to how they went
about and ban Donald Trump how they went
ahead and killed the hunter Biden laptop
story and made sure that you couldn't
share it in your DMs
those are your private messages and all
of that stuff how do they Shadow ban and
when did they decide to do it to certain
people and was their coordination with
the government when it came to covid
misinformation which was mostly being
spread by the CDC and fauci you guys get
all that so I so where it's going to be
in a year from now it's like I think the
guy can do incredible incredible things
with it but at the same time like in the
hand of government just wreck him can
they look into every one of his other
businesses as Joe Biden said and once
the government starts looking into
something you think they can find
something
like you know and at the same time he's
trying to get us to Mars so I would like
him to keep his eye on that ball too
right it would be nice to maybe go to
Mars and see what's going on over there
uh Truman says do you think someone
inside Trump's Inner Circle
intentionally didn't tell him about
Fuentes being present with Kanye in
order to sabotage his campaign it's hard
to see the whole debacle as anything
other than a hit job so I kind of
referenced this the other day this is
why it's bad for Trump if Trump knew
that he was sitting down with a guy that
is in a vowed white supremacist and
that's I'm not even calling Fuentes that
that's what he calls himself he believes
that black people and white people
should basically be living in separate
societies those are his own words right
uh if Trump knew that then it's a
hundred percent on Trump but let's
pretend Trump didn't know that and I
actually believe that he probably didn't
know who Nick Fuentes was I find it a
little more difficult to believe that he
didn't know who Milo was
um but okay let's just give Trump the
benefit of the doubt there if Kanye who
was set up like it's in the schedule
right we're having we're having lunch or
we're having dinner Trump and Kanye uh
so okay you're good to go there but if
Kanye shows up with some other people
Trump has to have I have no doubt that
he does have and I've been to marlago
like you got to show ID there's people
that check uh your information all that
stuff someone has to vet that for him
and if it got by the people that vet so
so you know they bet they should look at
the ID okay nikuentes somehow it gets by
marlago is a big place there's a lot of
people there someone had to go up to
Trump or somebody close to Trump and say
uh just FYI this is going to cause you a
problem so for Trump not to have the
right people around him I think shows
the deficiency so regardless of whether
it was a mistake or intentional or
as I think you're alluding to and I
think Tim Poole is kind of saying the
same thing it sort of feels like like
Kanye actually set Trump up that he
brought him there to make Trump look bad
because Kanye wants to run for president
as insane as that sounds so the whole
thing is very very weird but I think it
was a really bad week for Trump you know
the other guys hopefully will just be
little footnotes in history Kanye's
obviously not going to be president but
there's just not a I feel like
everyone's just over all that nonsense
we just want competency we want
competency and decency out of our
leaders we or our elected officials I
don't like call them leaders uh we don't
want just like the endless nonsensical
games and and all that stuff and also
it's like surround yourself with some
decent people man uh Tony says any
chance I can pay you eight bucks and get
one of those Nifty verified check marks
on locals we're trying to figure out how
to do some kind of verified thing on
there I don't think it'll be related to
money actually I don't think I think
there's some other clever ways we can do
that I think it would be something like
you've been in the community for x
amount of time I don't I don't think we
have to charge people more for that so
like if you're a paying member for say
six consecutive months you could get
some kind of badge we're working on that
and by the way a million people keep
asking me this we are working on the
bundling thing it's very complex so I
know a lot of you want bundling because
if you subscribe to me and say Viva and
Scott Adams and Greg Gutfeld or whoever
it might be I know we can add up and you
don't want to pay you know 50 bucks a
month for x amount of people whatever it
might be so we're trying to figure out
it's just very complex because everyone
wants to get their share and everything
else but we are working on a couple
things uh and we have a couple other big
app updates on that coming soon uh Megan
says if you could choose one news Outlet
to stay informed without the Clutter
what news Outlet or source
would you recommend uh that's sort of
like the other question
um
well look I'm with the Blaze and I think
they do a really fine job you know they
if you read the blazes basic
journalism stuff I'm not talking about
the opinion stuff like it's pretty
straightforward and clean it really is I
think daily wire obviously does a really
nice job as well you know in terms of
mainstream stuff it's almost impossible
at this point you know Wall Street
Journal I suppose is a little more
middle of the road than most but like
you know if you're reading the New York
Times and you're watching CNN and the
rest of it you're just being led down
the wrong path and we know that probably
40 percent of the country is at the end
of that path with you so it's it's a big
problem I would say try to get try to
look at a couple different sources and
if the headlines all seem exactly the
same or too obvious there's probably a
reason for that uh Curtis says Dave
would it be a smart tactical maneuver to
hold hearings on the events of January 6
once they the Republicans regained
control of the house
uh I don't know look they're they're
gonna look into the hunter Biden laptop
thing I think there is value in that
because there's a direct link from
intelligence services to our right to
free speech right so like that makes
sense to me I think people would rather
them work on the economy work on the
border that kind of stuff like this do
the Republicans now need to have like a
counter clown show for January 6 just to
show you that Liz Cheney is ridiculous
and that Adam kinzinger is a fool and
and the rest of these people are are all
hacks right like they didn't get Trump
on any of the impeachments the 17
impeachments impeached for walking down
a ramp slowly impeach for drinking water
with two hands all that stuff they
didn't get them on any of that they
didn't get them on this Mar-A-Lago
document um they're they're just not
going to get him on any of these things
I don't know that the idea of like the
Revenge Congress that comes in to now
investigate them I I just it's what I
said before competency people I think
people want the government mostly out of
your life and for the few few things
that they do just kind of do it well and
and get out of our way I think that's a
much better strategy for the Republicans
Amy Says what's your take on drama or
infighting that goes on behind the
political scenes of the political
commentator world oh you're going to get
me in trouble here example might be if
you find out a former guest was really a
bad dude or a gal and people are calling
them on you to cancel them or if it
turns out some well-spoken podcast hosts
is a total jerk on their personal lives
off screen how do you think the
professionals or the audience should
handle such things
man if they would have just heard our
conversation right before the show
started they would they would have a
little insight
um it's really tough it's tough because
once you become friends with the people
that are on your show or that you're
interviewing there is a different level
there that it's just human nature you're
probably going to give them a little bit
of a longer leash than you might give
somebody that you don't know that's
something I think about all the time
when I'm because obviously I'm
interviewing some people that I've
become friendly with over time right so
there there's definitely some truth to
that it makes it a little bit trickier
and I think it can blur those lines I
think if you're upfront about it right
so like for example you know a couple
weeks ago when we did those shows in DC
I had Rand Paul on well I've now
interviewed him many many times uh you
know we're friendly I think I obviously
think he's a decent guy and I like a lot
of his ideas it's like am I going to
interview him like with the outward like
full-on I'm gonna try to get you
probably not probably not I think I can
ask questions in the right way
but it's it's a it's a tough game but I
think you're also asking about sort of
like the personal side like if someone
just turns out to be a total dick or a
liar or whatever it's like look I've had
guests on this show that have turned on
me one of the reasons that we wanted to
get the the studio show out of my house
was you know I was inviting all sorts of
people into my house people that in some
cases now publicly don't like me or say
mean things about me I'm not asking them
for to be censored
um but I just felt like you know
politics is so weird it makes so many
people so crazy that uh
but yeah you don't necessarily want it
all in your house so that's one of the
reasons that we switched what we're
doing here and why we have the the local
studio now and uh and yeah some of the
people I've interviewed have turned out
not to be that great I suspect that some
people that I've done their shows don't
think I'm that great
um but uh you just try to do the best
you can and I think if you're roughly
honest and decent like the other stuff
kind of slides away uh Frank says how is
Clyde adjusting to not being the only
baby at home well Clyde is literally
right here right now quite any chance
you want to jump up on the desk for me
or something oh he's standing here I'll
shake his collar so you can hear he's
actually here
um
he's being extremely good at the moment
you know I told you guys when we uh when
we moved to Florida Clyde went bananas
because there's so many freaking lizards
and frogs and iguanas and all this stuff
that he was really really nuts so we had
to get him retrained for the kids
because obviously we didn't want him
jumping on the kids and limiting The
Barking so that they could take naps and
all that stuff he was really good for a
couple of months but the last two months
basically since Luke got here Lucas is
number two since Luke got here Clyde is
definitely feeling some level of neglect
here I'm going to take a picture of
Clyde that I'll post in the uh in the
locals community so you can see his uh
what he's doing right now just watching
he's he's literally just watching the
show there you go man
um so we got him retrained because we're
because he's being neglected not
neglected like I feed the guy oh how you
doing man
um
he's uh he wants more belly Rubes that's
what it really comes down to so after
the show today now that you've brought
it up I will spend a few minutes rubbing
his belly but he's a good dog
all right guys uh that is it for today
we've got a a panel show tomorrow
bringing back the Friday panel
Extravaganza if you haven't subscribed
rumble.com Ruben report
reubenreport.locals.com
uh oh and my interview uh with Miami
mayor Suarez uh and local CEO of soft
love will be out this afternoon on all
platforms and we leave you ladies and
gentlemen
Kamala Harris
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]